and
the way should we
is the wall street we want a government
that represents the people we want our
taxes to represent what we're paying
them for which is you know to create
housing and to create jobs I think
capitalism is it is the best economic
system that anybody has come up with as
long as it is regulated being on the
inside you've got to have progressive
leaders who are willing to stand up to
the right wing in this country who can
hoop now on the control the media but
control of government because right now
it doesn't matter what your issue is the
best we're getting is dead lock or
band-aid solutions or just completely
ignored I've seen the environment
evolved like you can't even imagine it
started with some college students out
here on sep tember seventh I see
veterans who are opposed to this war
spending I see a lot more organizations
coming lending their support and see a
lot more unions I see some senior
citizens who are scared about their
their Medicare their social security so
I see people all walks of life will just
fed up so if you can bring people out
and talk with them and network and tell
miss free food and come out sometimes
and I mean seriously I've brought people
out under the guise of hey it's free
food then I come back two days later and
then still here do they bother tyranny
one thing to get involved people ask me
why I'm here I'll ask you why you're not
here even if you're not ready
March or say something or make a clever
sign just literally being present is
power in numbers
I teach so I feel like I don't even need
a microphone you should probably just
shout loud enough for everyone to hear
me but you can all hear me in the back
now yes okay great aye manya shukran and
i'm your moderator tonight for this huge
and illustrious panel which is befits
the importance of this of the subject
which is an Occupy Wall Street I'm not
going to read everyone's bios because
they're just as in time but I was very
excited when Rose Hackman and Christina
Arabic and Layla loam and asked me to
moderate tonight because it's a very
interesting interdisciplinary mix we've
got people from economics from human
rights from law and from the business
school as well as two of our very own
Columbia protesters so we'll be hearing
about a whole lot of different views on
the on the protests I want to quickly
thank the Italian Academy Tatro for
letting us use the space as well as the
institute for the study of human rights
the Human Rights Institute
and Melanie Aronson whose film terrific
film we just saw I think obviously I
spent the year visiting protests around
the world not just today finish my book
on the global protest so i'm really
excited you know for me the only
question about Occupy Wall Street was
what took us so long but I think we'll
begin with Jeff Sachs who's terrific new
book I just finished reading last
weekend Jeff in your book you really
call for sort of new civic engagement
and a new contract in America and you're
actually quite optimistic about the
potential for activism in this country
and I I know you spent time down at
Occupy Wall Street I was wondering if
this fits with some of what you've been
sort of hoping for and expecting
and you thank you very much
I was absolutely delighted i did at
first i thought Randolph house must have
set it up in in line with the book
coming out because the the last chapter
of my book said it's going to be the
Millennials that are going to turn this
country around not at my generation and
I think it's really true
the baby boomers are leaving a mess
I think the Millennials have to start
fixing it faster perhaps than they
expected and I think that the Occupy
movement is the beginning of that so let
me give you a few minutes of quick take
from my perspective of what this is
about and I think Anya is right that
this is part of a worldwide phenomenon
but each country has its own
characteristics and each part of the US
that's part of this has its own
characteristics as well I believe that
the basic drama is about a society which
has become
very honorable and very unfair and that
the main motivation of Occupy Wall
Street is to address inequality and
inequity in other words not only the
spread of income and wealth and power
but the unethical and often illegal
basis of it as well and these are
appropriate targets and there are part
of a hallowed US history of self
correction when we have gotten so out of
balance as we are today
it's amazing what this movement has
accomplished in 10 weeks it hasn't
changed America in terms of the income
distribution and wealth and power but it
has changed the self understanding of
America to an almost unimaginable extent
this is just since the middle of
September and almost nothing in America
moves like that and I believe that well
we will see many different variants of
protest and unrest and activism in the
years ahead I don't think this is the
beginning or the end it's the beginning
of it in a way I don't think it's the
end of it and I don't think it will be a
culminating event in the near term but I
think that it has already been a
transformative one that will get a
process started that we have sorely
missed for three decades
there are four elements that I think are
broken in the American economy and
politics right now
each one has many dimensions to it the
first is inequality where as everybody
knows the vast proportion of gains of
income in the last 30 years have accrued
to the very top of the income
distribution and the median men's
earnings peaked actually 38 years ago in
1973 even as the economy grew meaning
that the games were at the top knot in
the middle and of course at the bottom
there have been absolute declines of
living standards so the gaps between
rich and poor widen to an extent that
we've not seen since nineteen twenty
nine on the eve of the Great Depression
and a lot of the underlying causes of
that our similar in terms of politics my
own view is that it's both market forces
of globalization and politics led by the
wealthy essentially that amplified the
market forces and led to a kind of
inequality that has not seen almost
anywhere else in the high-income
democracies
the second element of this is impunity
it's not only that there's a vast gap of
wealth and power I'm sorry you've asked
out of wealth and income there is
impunity at the top impunity means that
you can break the rules whether there
are social norms or whether they're laws
and walk away from it pretty much
unscathed and I think that impunity is
one of the biggest dangers of American
society Wall Street behaved absolutely
not only recklessly and irresponsibly
and not only via not only got
inexcusable handouts that were
uncontrolled in their subsequent use and
not only pocketed handouts for continued
vast billions of dollars of bonuses but
broke the law and broke the law badly
along the way and committed massive
financial fraud it lead up to the
financial crash in 2008 the SEC has
slapped the risk of the companies for
breaking the law and committing
financial fraud notably three recent
settlements against Citigroup bank of
america and goldman sachs i'm sorry
citigroup jpmorgan and goldman sachs
cited each of these firms for joining up
with a hedge fund to package toxic
assets that were known to be on the path
to failure and then to have the
investment banks or commercial banks
sell those toxic assets to unwitting
buyers so that the hedge funds could bet
against them and in the end Goldman paid
560 million dollars of fines JP Morgan
150 million dollars and Citigroup was
supposed to pay 270 million dollars
until Judge Rakoff last week throughout
the agreement saying that it didn't
serve the public interest and that it
had to go to trial because
Citigroup had not admitted guilt only
had consented to pay a fine and the
judge wisely ruled that's not good
enough this has to be adjudicated I
think this illegal T and impunity is
massively important for what's happening
and the fact that CEOs that were part of
this still go to the state dinners and
are still honored guests at the White
House is disgusting and it's the way
that our country works right now and
it's one of the reasons why people are
out in this movement the third aspect of
this is the generalized corruption of
our political system so not only
breaking financial laws but the fact
that money infuses every part of our
politics in the most egregious weighs in
at least modern history we've been here
before but we cleaned it up and now
we're here again and we now know that
it's not only the seven billion dollars
perhaps of the next election cycle it's
not only the four billion dollars a year
of the lobbying that are part of the
corruption but the book by Peter
Schweitzer of the Hoover Institute
details that it's also pure insider
trading by Congress so it's not even the
subtlety of I'll do for you if you
finance my campaign it's rather I want
to get rich I'll write laws for you and
I'll trade on that with insider
information absolutely grotesque and
this is a major part of our problem and
the fourth part that I would highlight
finally is the decay of government
investments and services while we see
government most visibly as the military
with all its
violations I would say of what is right
for our foreign policy not that they're
directing it it's it's a series of
presidents and congresses that have
directed that but while we see the
military and we see social security and
medicare as the headlines of our
government what has been broken in the
last 30 years are the day-to-day
programs of job training and education
grants and investments in infrastructure
and cleaning up the environment and
doing research on renewable energy and
all the rest that has been gutted and
I'm sorry to say the president obama is
not protecting that it's just going down
almost to zero in the agreement that was
reached in august to put it precisely
all of the discretionary non-security
budget is on a path to be less than two
percentage points of our national income
by the end of this decade for
environment energy job training
education National Science Foundation
space science climate everything we're
gutting the government and this is why
it feels so bad for so many people also
because people need government services
unless you're rich and you can pay for
them yourself but even the rich are
going to find out and certainly their
kids that a destroyed environment and
massively unreduced climate change and
the decay of our society and the unrest
and all the rest is going to even find
their way beyond the gated communities
so this is what's wrong and what the
protest is about I believe that we're at
the beginning of a new era I I have
called it in my own thinking the new
progressive movement because I like in
our time to the end of the 19th century
and the Gilded Age when a
large scale social transformation
occurred it lasted roughly 25 years and
are one of the great historians of
America Arthur Schlesinger jr. used to
talk about waves of roughly 20 to 30
years between private purpose or profit
motive dominated and public purpose were
correction and reform dominated and I
believe were at the beginning of one of
those periods now at the end of the
Gilded Age you remember that william
jennings bryan said in 1896 that we will
not be crucified on a cross of gold and
help transform the populist movement
into a progressive movement muckrakers
that wrote about the scandals of big
corporate power exposed the abuses that
we now see exposed in Rolling Stone and
on websites and have a much faster
turnaround time and opensecrets.org and
many other places and America was lucky
that teddy roosevelt became president
the first great national leader of the
Progressive Era was Republican president
who came to power by an assassination of
his boss because the Republicans
certainly didn't expect Teddy Roosevelt
to be President but when he became
president he understood his class
because he came from it and he wrestled
it back under control to an important
extent and the second great progressive
leader was the president just next after
the next Woodrow Wilson and if you look
at the era from roughly 1902 1917 when
America entered World War one the amount
of change from the graduated income tax
to labor standards to effective
antitrust action to direct election of
senators to women's suffrage was
absolutely astounding one of the most
productive periods of reform in any
modern democracy anywhere
and I think that the new deal was
another era like this and the 1960s was
another era like this and I believe that
we are entering another error but not
that it just swings like a pendulum you
have to make it do that that's actually
your job you better do it because really
were in a miserable shape and it's worse
than it looks right now because not only
do we have all those problems of
corruption and inequality and young
people that can't make it and can't find
jobs can't get through school can't
carry student loans but lurking behind
that are very very very serious crises
that are completely unaddressed like
climate change because of the corruption
of our political system and until we get
control of that we're on a writ on a way
to ruin that's even far more significant
than what we have right now so this is
your homework actually it's not going to
be done by the Occupy movement it's
going to be started by that there's a
lot ahead it's years it's years believe
me nothing has changed nothing except
the eyes are now open that's the great
starting point now we have to continue
with facts with information with
muckraking with descriptions with
analysis you have to continue with
activism we have to as shareholders go
into companies and get them to stop
anonymous political contributions we
have to have shareholder initiatives we
have to have consumer boycotts against
the abuse of companies we have to have
students organized around the country we
have to move towards policies not in
eight weeks that's a stupid complaint
they don't have policies well we're
shakin
their confidence that's enough of a
policy right now because the impunity is
being recognized for what it is and the
lawlessness is being called out right
now and they're scared which is good
because they ought to be because they've
had it easy and now suddenly suddenly
they're being looked at and people are a
little bit amazed and aghast at what
they see finally we're going to need and
you're especially going to need politics
because this won't end actually without
elected people and reforming the process
the incumbents will not reform the
political process don't say that you
need campaign reform campaign finance
reform first it's not going to happen
that way Teddy Roosevelt wasn't able to
do what he did because campaign reform
came first or Franklin Roosevelt or
other leaders you need to elect leaders
who will change we thought we had one
I'm sorry we don't because we haven't
had the change that we needed President
Obama brought Wall Street right back
into the White House he brought all the
lobbies right back in it's been awful
the lost opportunity of 2008 we're going
to have to do a lot better and you're
going to have to do a lot better I have
one particular recommendation on the
politics and that is that the next
generation of politicians is going to
have to win without accepting any large
campaign contributions it's not going to
be we'll take good rich money and fight
bad rich money you're going to need
clever candidates who are smart enough
to say I don't take any money beyond $99
that's my limit and my opponent does and
he's bought and I'm not bought and
that's got to be the way to come in and
we
have to provide i believe the social
networks the viral videos the free media
the free exposure that makes it possible
now you guys know how to do that better
than any generation in history you don't
need a billion dollars to get your
message out one very good will.i.am
video is definitely worth more than 50
million dollars of professional paid
advertisements and that was a YouTube
and I don't know how many times you
watched it I watched it 50 times at
least showing it to people because it
was so great and I was so excited I was
I don't know about you but I loved it do
better even but it's free so that's what
I would recommend you can't beat the
money with money but you can beat the
money with the truth thanks very much
thank thank you so much I know you have
to go to a benefit so that's why it's
World AIDS Day very very important and
just one word on you sorry the United
States is not even fulfilling its
commitment to the Global Fund to fight
AIDS TB and malaria because our politics
are so rotten that we can't find the 1.3
billion dollars a year to fulfill
straightforwardly our commitment and
because of that last week the Global
Fund canceled round 11 and this is the
single most devastating setback in the
fight against AIDS TB and malaria in
more than a decade and that 1.3 billion
dollars that they couldn't just simply
confirm on time no nonsense is 16 hours
of the years Pentagon spending so they
couldn't even find one day's Pentagon
spending to save millions of lives and
that's the shame of it and I gotta go
say that next door so thanks very much
thank you very much Jeff and now we're
going to hear from Suresh and I do from
the Economics Department who's been
spending a lot of time down at Occupy
Wall Street okay so last time I spoke in
public about Occupy Wall Street I ended
with i thought the most important thing
was to hold the park and so that didn't
work and but i also sort of you know i'm
not particularly sad about it I mean I'm
a little bit sad about it because I did
think having the having the space was
important but I did serve really echo
what Jeff said about this being just
kind of the opening salvo maybe the
second salvo in kind of a long sort of
fight against kind of a 30-year sort of
agenda of privatizing everything
deregulating everything and not just in
the United States right so that in lots
of the developing world that this agenda
has also been moving has been moving
full steam ahead and so my sort of
generations and I think a lot of the the
sort of the elders and occupy which were
which is sort of like the 30-somethings
and that that you know we came out of
like the global justice movement of like
the 1990s and early 2000s and you know
we had very much sort of a very similar
style of organizing and you know very
similar very similar politics of sort of
the initial at least what what started
around occupying and and so I just
wanted to point out that for all of
these things that we think of as being
in the as being about the u.s. that in
fact I think a lot of these issues were
global and that a lot of the inspiration
around occupation and occupy is global
and that both in the inspiration that
the activists draw from the zapatistas
or from the more immediate inspiration
that we got from holding space from
coming from Tahrir the indignados or the
or people over the world is like
literally we learned a lot
from from lots and lots of movements
that have been fighting sort of
privatization and and and deregulation
all over the world so I just wanted to
put them in some some context and sort
of go-between what happened a lot of
those other struggles and what is
probably going to happen here is that
there's a really important step between
protests and elections and I don't think
people like oh is occupied gonna go into
the Democratic Party and how is that
going to look and there's this entire
intermediate level of organizations that
it looks like labor unions and so the
reason that Dorian isn't here today is
because and I'm taking his spot is
because he had to go testify at the NLRB
today in order to make sure because
they're passing a tiny rule change that
would shorten the amount of time between
announcing an election a union law
collection and having one and that it
was going to go from 60 days to 30 days
and and a Republican that's on the board
of the National of the NLRB is going to
resign in order to dine it denied quorum
so that I can't pass this role and so
they're going to you know he's quite
willing I mean that's that's ideology
that's and said that's why didn't you
know he's willing to resign in order to
prevent this very tiny rule change and
said Dorian is going to sort of work on
that in DC and the point of that is that
in between sort of a protest and in
between like getting a lot of people
exercised and and and and doing actions
and getting really excited when movement
and actual policies and institutions is
political organization and that means a
whole level of organizations that where
you're doing door knocking where you're
handing out pamphlets where you're kind
of doing the the less exciting work of
I'm just kind of getting people into
politics and that doesn't mean getting
them into elections necessarily again
but it means getting them get going out
and doing doing political education
and and so that sort of level and I
think a lot of OWS is very cognos that I
mean that's why sort of we went to bat
for the south of these workers in
dealing with dealing with you know
Michael sovereign and and and and
working with the Teamsters on that's why
we went out and helped with foreclosure
activism and so because there's a lot of
sort of people that really understand
that what will make this more than just
sort of the people in the park or more
than occupy will be taking that energy
and using it to build organizations and
organizations are that intermediate
level between people's beliefs and
policy and so that's that's kind of got
to be the the the intermediate sort of
step and I think we're seeing that I
mean the people are working on all sorts
of things along those lines I mean I
know there's that there's the yeah so
there's and part of that is going to
involve like more disruption I mean I
want to sort of go to bat for the
radicalism of OWS for this idea that
like where you actually have your
political power isn't isn't necessarily
you know you don't have it with your
dollars what you have it with is your
ability to either stop working or hold
public space or actually sort of disrupt
and impose costs with your because you
don't have money so you should use your
bodies and so that those sort of those
tactics of disruption are kind of really
important and and I want to can I go to
my graph now oh no sorry Suresh going to
your graph later
I guess oh really fast there's your f
and then okay super by yeah thank you
okay so so this is a graph from Douglas
McAdams at 1983 paper and sociology on
the civil rights movement so this is
1955 through 1962 and these are the big
solid line is is movement actions and
there's a couple of things about this
graph i really like one is the time
scale this goes from 55 to 62 and you'll
see that for a long time it's a lot of
like low level stuff going on and then
you start seeing as sort of a really big
spike and then it's sort of when you
show this the physicist there like that
looks like an earthquake that's like
something you'd read off in a
seismometer and the other thing about it
that's sort of the point of the paper is
actually how much the the new spikes are
driven by by tactical innovation that
the first big spike is is when is when
sit-ins sort of become a tactic and so
then you just see this explosion of
sit-ins in civil rights and then that
dies down and then people come up with
these community campaigns and then that
takes off and so I think there's some
momentum that like this immediate sir
short sharp bursts and then like a
collapse and then or another one that
this is sort of how social movements
look and that they look this was
disruptive and sojer twin civil rights
is first getting off like everybody in
the United States thought why did they
have to be making such a fuss you know
why why can't they're gonna they're
actually making things worse for
themselves by doing these sort of really
disruptive tactics they should work
through their they should work through
their you know they should work through
the policy process and wait for change
to happen and and so and the majority of
Americans thought that this was you know
this was kind of crazy and but then as a
going it took three years and then it's
basically was like wow even in the North
people's opinions started changing so so
that's sort of the though I think the
lessons of this graph are sort of the
these three things one is sort of the
of tactics the second is the long time
horizon that it goes from getting like
protests into you know you still don't
get the Voting Rights Act until three
years after this and so this is as Jeff
said this is a long run fight and then
the second thing is going to be the next
phase of this is going to be a tactical
innovation I think it's going to be some
and you know there's a lot of smart
people and they're thinking about lots
of interesting things and you know as a
friend of mine said there's lots of
banks downtown and their doors both open
and closed and it doesn't matter who's
opening and closing them and so that
it's that there's just a lot of like
disruptive creative tactical actions
that are going to happen out there and
that's going to be kind of the next wave
and I anticipate sometime in the spring
I think that's right that's really
interesting Suresh I think obviously
part of what brings about change is
public opinion as well which obviously
Occupy Wall Street's done an incredibly
good job of mobilizing that and changing
the discussion very quickly as dr. Sachs
pointed out I was talking to an Egyptian
activists today we were sort of
comparing to her square in January and
Tahrir Square last week and he said that
Mubarak didn't understand that when he
set his thugs on the crowds it
immediately put public sympathy on on
the side of the protesters and that that
was actually the tipping point in many
ways so the police response has
obviously been complicated and
unpleasant in most cases I mean we can
argue that Bloomberg has done more to
help the protesters than anybody else by
his tactic so I really wanted to bring
um professor bargain from the human
rights program at ciba into the
conversation because I know you had a
little bit to talk about they the police
response to some of what we've seen hi
well first of all thank you hey first of
all I'm very glad to hear the previous
speakers optimism that's great both Jeff
in you I mean this is wonderful the idea
that we are the dawn of a new era is not
what actually what I expected but it's I
wish that were true even if it's a long
term but I thought maybe I should stand
up I thought that day I should I wanted
to speak about a couple of things first
of all about freedom of speech and
secondly about police respond
and these are the two things that I
think we learned from the from the
movement and from the demonstrations
with regard to freedom of speech this is
sort of a real critical aspect of
American public space that we believe we
strongly believe in freedom of speech
however assigning and giving freedom of
speech to cooperation on one thing and
denying freedom of speech from people
who actually put their body on the line
has become a really confusing in terms
of the relations of common relations of
freedom of speech in our common sense of
understanding it there's always tension
between government and a the
inconvenience for the government of
demonstrations and opposition's and
critique and they say we should have
shown that probably there is a good
YouTube piece of having a obama in
clinton exalting the various
demonstrations around the world and the
various freedom of speech the importance
of freedom of speech and hillary clinton
today is in burma really celebrating the
opposition and we all remember the
buddhists being repressed is so strongly
by the regime a tool 33 years ago so i
think that the myopia and the
discrepancy between on the one hand
celebrating freedom of speech and on the
other hand resulting into technicalities
technicalities a long time place and
manner as though they it's only an
objective bureaucratic administrative
decision that yeah we can let you speak
as long as you don't do it now as long
as you don't do it here as long as you
don't disrupt anything we can agree on
time manner in place which is never is
too early and nowhere is the play
in a city like New York there is not a
single space where people can put their
body on the line and actually display
and demonstrate in the mid in the
literary sense of the word what they
believe in this is obviously something
that is very corrupt so I think that
that's the first thing that we learned
in terms of the limitation now that's
not you obviously we just saw the civil
rights movement a graph and that has
been done in the past but I think this
is one issue that when we compare
ourselves to everywhere to other places
in the world whether it's Prague in 68
or Gdansk in the 80s Otis do you think
that Mubarak wanted time manner and
place for the Terrell and didn't tell
them that they need to move on that it's
enough that they ruin the city life or
in Tiananmen Square was it occupying the
square and that was for six weeks from
februari to June that's enough you
should go but here it looks almost
reasonable so I think that I'm actually
not optimistic I'm actually quite
passing me quite quite a pessimist in
terms of viewing the idea that mayor's
can actually determine the public space
because the worst thing that you can do
worse than public then freedom of speech
if step on the long ruined my day a face
of the central of his tiny square in the
city which brings me to the second point
I wanted to make which is about police
since 99 there is an increased
militarization of the police we can't
breathe we can't build a militarized
police and then keep it on occupy
unemployed so if there is a military
police they'll find an object now I
don't know if Bloomberg and in
anticipation permission of what I'm
going to say but he sort of provided the
perfect quote yesterday or the day
before actually when he spoke in at MIT
and he says that I have my own larger
seventh largest army in the world I'm
quoting according for memory but I think
I'm pretty close to the my own
first of all than my own right it's not
city that has the police force it's the
mayor when that's actually quite
reasonable when we talk about the one
percentile when a person that the
richest person in the city can buy a
third term as opposed to everything else
and then when he makes the money from
Wall Street and then Italy clears the
demonstrators they propose I i we don't
need real social analysis to see what
connects to what it's not really very
critical but then when the
anti-terrorist unit of the NYPD sends a
memo describing the movements of the
demonstrators going down from a ducati
park to Wall Street why the
anti-terrorist move a unit what do they
have to do with it what kind of
terrorism is there I think the fear is
not that the NYPD's particularly bad
it's that this is the public discourse
the fear of anything that actually
interfere with orderly facade so we have
clearing from all the country and nobody
is even asking why clear the people
what's wrong with it so what if people
sit in the public space the question is
whether it's more violent or less
violent the particular it's a movement
that has had absolute zero violence
against the police one hundred percent
of violence by police against
demonstrators and it seems reasonable
then apology here we regret here but
altogether the police is doing things
that they shouldn't be doing in the
first place so maybe we will maybe after
everybody goes home for the holidays
come back and snow melts and everything
the spring will have a bigger
demonstration I don't know I'm afraid
that the limitation of speech that
allowing cooperation to freedom of
action with and I don't want to get into
a whole analysis
here but then the corporation's become
the beneficiaries of freedom of speech
and people lose it we in a very tight
situation when the police is becoming
militarized they'll find the target and
the target is us thank you Peter what
room is there for human rights in this
discussion so I was gonna give a very I
was gonna get a depressing talk about
how the human rights movement is always
three steps behind when it comes to
where activism is but I think there's a
bright side to the story as well which
is that the human rights movement is
tend to learn from the activists you
know when when Amnesty International hit
the ground there was no human rights
movement and the people that were part
of it really didn't care what was in un
documents or treaties they acted in
accordance with their own with their
with their ethics and their morals and
then they and they insisted on a on a
set of rules that eventually became the
rules of a movement and the tactics of a
movement that for its time served an
important purpose and in fact everything
that we've seen in terms of the progress
of the human rights movement over time
has come with activists who haven't
cared what was actually in the rules and
have shocked those who are the keepers
of those rules along the way and even
those who work in the human rights
organizations or at the United Nations
or elsewhere who think of themselves
often as the guardians of that system so
whether it was the Seattle protesters
who brought the issues of economic
justice back to human rights in a way
that it needed to be or whether later on
it was people I exactly achmad and the
AIDS protesters because you know when
the treatment action campaign and act up
and others stood up for the rights of
treatment the human rights lawyers were
there to say well you know there are
patents and there are rules and there
are costs that are involved and there's
property but within a period of three
four years that was gone you didn't hear
that kind of complaint anymore
costs were driven down and the drug
companies were forced to react and
people generally came to see something
that that hadn't previously been
recognized as such as a human rights
issue so as someone coming out and
studying the human rights movement over
time I look on the one hand and see that
it's a movement that's that served
purposes but has had to catch up with
the activist and when it's come to the
economic issues is still three steps
behind it's begun to catch up with the
issues that Suresh has talked about
which the privatization around the world
and the way that that's undermined the
abilities of governments everywhere to
fulfill the rights that are in the
treaties it's begun to look at the right
to a to an equitable tax structure so
that governments have the resources and
that people are required to pay in such
a way that the obligations they've
committed to can be met it's begun to
look at the ways that privatization
itself is a way of undermining the
rights that people have but it's it's
not going anywhere on those issues
without the activists of the as we've
seen the path of the generations of of
the active treatment action campaign
Seattle protesters and the rest and I
think that that's not something we can
fault it for it's just it's something
it'll-it'll it's a it's a space to
occupy and I and I and I hope that
you'll do it because there are and there
are spaces though that have been that
have been opened for your occupation I
agree with zuri the the freedom of
speech the privatizing of space is the
controlling of time but there's a lot of
things out there there's a lot of places
that that that are that are inviting our
occupation for making these arguments
and for pushing them forward as I was
listening to Jeff Sachs and thinking
about the the corporations and holding
corporations to account and thinking
about a generation of students maybe
suresh's generation who protested
sweatshop labor and and brought the
issues to campuses and woke up companies
around the United States and elsewhere
to issues of Labor around the world that
they hadn't paid attention to before
help to put into place some mechanisms
that frankly the students and the
activists have let lie fallow I don't
know how many of you know that there is
at Columbia University an advisory
committee on socially responsible
investment that reports to the trustees
on how they should vote their shares
that reports to the trustees on what the
issues are that the Columbia community
cares about when it comes to its
investments it's huge endowment anyone
are you take them over I'm a member I'm
waiting for them take it over it's a
space that hasn't heard the the deeper
concerns about what's happening in terms
of investments the issues that Jeff
mentioned about corporate giving
anonymous giving the ways that
corporations you know we've got all
these corporations with the smiling
faces including some that are
participating actively in the good guy
campaigns and then turn around and are
contributing whether it's you know the
target story in Minnesota and the
contributing to right-wing campaigners
or it's the ways that the Chamber of
Commerce or the National Association of
Manufacturers or any of the other
industry associations through anonymous
giving manages to undermine the efforts
that are otherwise being spoken of and
loud voice well you know what every
single one of the companies that
Columbia invests in and that every other
university investment has as a
shareholder resolution at this moment
last year next year it's going to be
their resolutions requiring them to
report on anonymous giving to stop the
anonymous giving to report on who
they've given their money to and where
it's going and it's going to be with
more pressure from the community that
we're going to get more accountability
for that and start to focus in more even
more closely on how we can hold these
companies to account and what more
they're doing that's a space to occupy
with a loud voice here at Columbia it's
the money of the universities that we
have it's the buying power of the
students that scares companies faster
than anything you can imagine there you
know the you might look back in some way
at the Nike campaigns or the others and
think well not that much was
accomplished but in fact huge awareness
huge connections and links to workers
move
once around the world and an awareness
of labor rights in a way that reached
further into the production sector than
ever before and and those are spaces
that we need to move into in the United
States just I mean in terms of the
depressing side of an issue that I think
has to go Abby at Columbia but be beyond
we think about corporations my you know
a mentor at the law school a real real
no figure moving the human rights
movement Lou henken when at one point
was writing and I was shocked to see
years ago he wrote that the most
depressing US Supreme Court case was a
case we've never heard of a case with
Bank of Boston and another company
involved and it was the first of the
cases that recognize that corporations
have freedom of speech but it was the
breakthrough in terms of seeing
corporations as individuals under the
system of American rights which is a
travesty and it can only be reversed
through massive efforts as well maybe a
constitutional amendment but it's a
travesty and it's even a worse when you
wear it's Travis Lee when you think that
those same corporations that are banking
off of that every day of the week are
the st. are the corporations that are
fighting in our courts here in New York
and a case going up to the Supreme Court
that's trying to say that corporations
can't be held liable for violations of
international law that the lawsuits the
Alien Tort Statute lawsuits to try and
get the responsibility of corporations
whether in south africa in issues of
apartheid or in the united states and
elsewhere for vast violations of the of
Rights that constitute international law
today that they are the same
corporations arguing that they are not
individuals that they cannot be held
accountable and that these this huge
contradiction is not something that we
are holding them to account for so I
think there are I think there are spaces
and their arguments on the constant on
that side the human rights movement is
not going to lead the way you are but
the human rights movement will follow
they have before and they'll do it again
when they're taught that these are basic
rights and that they're the ones that
have to be responded to today
thank you very much Peter and now I
think we'll hear from Professor Koga at
the business school so uh good evening
I'm not sure who you all are not sure
anyone knows so we were trying to figure
out to what to how we should direct our
comments so let me give you a few few
thoughts on this and carry over to
people who were actually involved in
occupying Wall Street and it's not nice
to see my colleagues Suresh talking
about these issues as well the I'm at a
business school which sometimes is
opaque to people what it does and what
it produces there was a professor who
went on to the jon stewart show on the
area of ethics and in the and they asked
him the question on how good of a job do
you think you're doing on the ethics
side and it was kind of silence in that
particular issue because obviously a lot
of students go out and are involved in
activities which Jeff Sachs described I
think I think with some exaggeration to
be honest really what but it's some
truth to that these a lot of things
happen in business which not exactly
sometimes Emily well nor is it true for
politics no is it true for many aspects
of life but what I think is important
about business schools and I see a few
of the students here from the business
school is that generally they come with
the same aspirations like almost anyone
you teach in the in the school they're
little bit different their little bit
more oriented towards careers in making
making money but they respond as well to
these issues of inequality thinking
about diversity in the workplace issues
of only two percent of the CEO is being
female for example the boards being only
twelve percent a female these issues
which are put forth we run a program at
the business school which I run on
leadership and ethics it's also the
social enterprise program where we talk
to groups nonprofits and also for profit
social enterprise trying to teach skills
of how to organize some of these people
are AB
kits so I ran a program last year the
year before under Rothschild money for
social entrepreneurs and Muslim Jewish
dialogue and in in the in that group
where people who are advocates you know
pushing ideas which is a little bit
different than what we've actually find
at the business school people want to
create organizations in my experience
I'm interested in people who actually
create organizations I'm interested in
people who are entrepreneurs and who
make things happen I think it starts
with advocacy that isn't always an end
without you see it ends with
organizational skills when I look at us
currently what I see is particular
dilemma which is very troubling Amanda I
can go through all the same facts you've
heard before but i would recommend a
book to you by a guy named hacker and
pearson called winner-take-all politics
which i think is absolutely brilliant
brilliant book goes through the
inequality numbers and then quality
numbers are I don't know something
between disgusting and and Beyond and
beyond belief currently but what's
interesting about what they put out is
this very short history of how we got
here and it goes something like this it
goes that about 30-40 years ago if you
were a Democrat you didn't have money
but you had an organization called labor
if you're Republican you had a lot of
money but you didn't know how to do
grassroots stuff and somewhere along the
way labor disappeared and the Democrats
are still without money and the
Republicans learned how to actually
organize things and in the 1990s mr.
Clinton president of some of some merit
decided that he wanted to win and he
went out and he formed an alliance with
Wall Street to fund democratic elections
and that was kind of a an agreement with
the devil if you wish but in some sense
it's what was successful in that period
of time if you look at mr. Obama we
basically say see the same thing we see
no labor in the in the u.s. we see no
organizations what we do see well
organized Republican
party and we see a polka party a lot of
money and we have to ask yourself what
should the Democrats do at this at this
moment and one answer is to allow
yourself again with with money and we've
seen this over the past decade what this
is brought us as broad as I won't give
you all the details of the tax policies
which you probably know or don't know
but let's just say the tax policies are
heavily skewed towards helping the rich
or people who are you heard Warren
Buffett talk about this in terms of he
pays less average tax than his secretary
does there is a skewering of the tax
thing which is absolutely incredible the
the issue the corporation is a person is
a funny quip about that is when I when I
see in a corporation executed in the
state of Texas is it is when I believe
it we it's a person but but leaving but
leaving that but they could equip aside
what bothers me most is really not so
much that issue which is which we can
talk about but is the fact that we no
longer know the first time many years
where the money comes from so we'll find
an election happening 2012 will be
massive amount of money and you will be
unable to trace the particular
particular money but we already see the
tent the swing so if you look at going
sax what we do know about money giving
they usually give fifty percent fifty
percent to the Democratic Party they've
already switched to eighty percent
Republican twenty percent to the
Democratic Party it's not surprising
it's shifting in that in that particular
particular direction so what should we
do in this in this kind of environment
where we don't find very strong
grassroots organizations for the
Democrats as we saw before we find every
well financed and very well executed
Republican a party what should be the
action and I think it's everyone's been
really pleased by seeing this amazing
movement come come across us there's
occupying Wall Street and saying you
know this is this place it's like likely
took the class in Business School and
advertising you know the 99 is just so
brung it innocent it's you know it's
your brilliant idea because it says
basically everyone has agreed in this
and it's so odd that people whether you
left or right people are agreed in the
fact there's something extraordinarily
wrong about this particular income
distribution so it
reached across the u.s. it didn't reach
to the left that reached across to the
US or was something and that to me is is
a winning as a winning idea and I'm
interested in having things when i'm not
interested in just having things
occupied as i'm sure you should you fear
you feel the same the same way so how do
we make things actually winning this in
this in this environment and one of them
i don't think is speaking too badly
about mr. obama i'm sorry to say this
but he hasn't done everything we wanted
but darn it you got a health care bill
you may think the dodd-frank doesn't do
very much but i guarantee you if you
look at how much lobbying money's
flowing to Washington right now trying
to shoot that thing down some people
think it actually does it does matter a
lot two wars are close to being to being
ended and troops being brought back
these are great things which we
shouldn't forget if if we want to put
value on these on these issues but
ultimately it's not going to be enough
going forward it's going to pend upon
organization I don't agree it's just
that it's just the responsibility where
it's only can be done through a certain
millennial generation because where
people are being hurt is across all age
groups including the people who are in
threat of losing the Social Security and
losing their long-term benefits this
isn't really an American issue which has
been well identified and put out very
very strongly so what I would like to
see and encourage you to do is to think
about how to organize the stuff I know
you talked at least you're so kind you
meet with me earlier and I know you hear
this from everyone on this but this is
where we are and I'm not sure it's just
the group of people who've occupied or
it's a wider issue but here I like to
say something which may be strike is
very odd is it actually business schools
if you leave aside the issues of profits
which bother a lot of people doesn't
bother me but bob is a lot of people if
you leave that alone what business
schools really do is teach people how to
organize effectively and how to organize
things to be effective the marketplace
advertising is one of them having pet
people being organized and coordinated
in a powerful way having effective
results with the proper use of financing
and I would be happy anytime you'd want
to organize with you and colleagues kind
of ideas of how we might organize these
issues so it's most effective in this
particular a bigger issue so we're
arguing the issues where we need now is
actually to see the consequences we all
desire thanks very much interestingly
one of the egyptian protesters i was
speaking to on the phone today told me
that the book which most influenced him
was from good to great which is a sort
of classic business school text yeah
isn't that interesting he said it made
him realize yeah the importance of some
of the points that you just talked about
I don't know I'd loved well one thing
I'd love to know about is what you think
of this new york magazine article this
week about the future of Occupy Wall
Street I don't know have you if you've
had a chance to look at that but that
argued very forcefully that there is a
that there is an organizational
structure behind the protest and that
they do have planned through the future
but that doesn't necessarily include
supporting Obama who so many people feel
really betrayed by we're really lucky to
have yesenia bargain and Alicia white
here today so I'd love to hear if you
want to react anything that the other
panelists said or maybe you want to talk
about something completely different but
please go for it and then we'll take
questions from the audience thank you
thank you thanks so I'm gonna let my
very dear and new friend we were both at
Occupy Wall Street but didn't meet each
other in the park which is not
surprising because it's a very populated
place when we were there address the
more immediate things that are upcoming
in organizational details yeah I'm
relatively small I'll stand hi hi
everybody so so I'm going to let you say
no talk about some more immediate
organizational concerns and to I think a
couple of people in the last week that
are even in this room have come up to me
and said that's so sad that it's over
now you must be you must be heartbroken
you've put so much effort into this and
I'm happy to say that that that's not
the case so yeah all right so uh so but
i will i'll leave that to you say no to
address there is an action tonight
though so if anybody's interested in
that i'll be changing my shoes and
hitting the pavement after this one
thing that I that I want to start with
is actually goes into that how has this
been so successful in movement building
and organizing and why has the appeal of
Occupy Wall Street worked so well and a
lot of people have said well it's the
it's the internet the Facebook age what
this happened because people can connect
and technology has allowed us to connect
to each other and now young people have
gotten into the square and I will admit
that it was technology that brought me
down to Liberty Square Zuccotti Park for
the first time I saw a video that a
friend took on the first day with their
cell phone they were marching and they
were I saw protesters marching with
signs there were police officers on the
side of the protest with these with
their belts just filled with those
plastic handcuffs all the way around and
I remember thinking that they looked
like bouquets of flowers in the way that
they bunch on their belts and the
protesters looked intimidated because
there weren't very many of us in the
very very beginning and I remember
seeing that video and my thought wasn't
about the economy and it wasn't about
systemic victimization of the poor and
the middle class and the erosion of
democracy in the United States my first
reaction to this was the people feel
threatened in public when they shouldn't
and that's why I went down I'm a
graduate student of human rights here
and I have a natural inclination for for
protecting the vulnerable right so I
went down to this to this community
because I didn't think that it was right
that a group of people in New York City
should enter the public space and feel
like they're threatened by the state as
simple as that whatever the belief is
and once I walked into it so you know
viral media got me there once I walked
into it there was no more internet we
didn't have Wi-Fi in the park unless you
were live streaming on one laptop in the
beginning we didn't have Wi-Fi you had
to go to mcdonalds down the street and
plug in your laptop if you had one it
wasn't about technology was about human
stories and sharing face-to-face and
scribbling on pieces of paper cell phone
numbers and saying please don't get
arrested with my phone number in your
cell phone that's what it was all about
it was people-to-people connections and
people-to-people stories and occupy wall
street to me became and has been so
successful because it really is that bad
here and I think that Professor Barkin
was touching on it a little bit in a way
that's been very viscerally real for us
I moved into the camp on day three and
my experience was absolutely horrifying
I cannot tell you I all of the
experience that I've experiences that I
have had with NYPD and it you know
doesn't rival living in East Harlem and
you know three days of stop-and-frisk
is about five minutes of Occupy Wall
Street right so having that experience
of changing my relationship with NYPD
and being a part of this community where
people are sharing stories about being
kicked out of their homes after
confusing foreclosure processes and
people who are leaving young people who
are leaving college after two semesters
because they couldn't finance their
education those personal connections
stories were the reason that so many
people were getting involved in this and
when you hear them again and again and
again from a thousand people that are
part of the community that you're
sleeping in you start to realize that it
really is that bad and that things
really really are getting that desperate
so I think that in a in an organizing
sense it wasn't hard for us to spread
really really quickly and resonate with
people in a really deep way because
tears were flowing and and that wasn't
difficult to achieve once people started
coming into the park so we we all know
that we have a situation right now where
Americans ordinary Americans are playing
by the rules and then losing in this
economy and it's really easy to have
slogans like the 99 percenters eng out
and one percent has been winning and it
of course that's going to be a
caricature of a very complicated systems
but but overwhelmingly it really seems
to be basically true unfortunately and
so when that's the when that's the basic
rallying cry of course we're going to
see people especially from the
background that I come from saying well
then is this is this a massive human
rights movement are we you know social
and economic rights are a real thing and
there are social and economic rights
that are being violated you know if you
if you believe in them they aren't they
aren't being honored in American context
so I had people asking me well are you
know Occupy Wall Street is a human
rights movement and isn't that exciting
and for better for worse from somebody
who is a part of the community and
of course I can only speak for myself
Human Rights was not something that was
articulated in Liberty Square almost at
all so that really reflects the you know
the experience on the ground I saw once
one sign about human rights that said
workers rights are human rights and it
was brought in during a labor march from
somebody that was not an Occupy Wall
Street protester that was a labor
protester that was joining us for like
an hour so to put that out there it
hasn't been articulated as a human
rights movement I don't think that it
will but I do think that it's a human
rights issue and that it gets power from
that those are different things but it's
still important finally in talking about
where we're going in the future
organizationally a lot of things are
happening it's definitely not over but
in a much broader sense I'm straddling
both sides a little bit I am not so
optimistic to think that this is the
beginning of a new progressive movement
for sure and that it's all going to be
much better and that a decade from now
everything's going to be just fine and
that my student debt will be forgiven
and that I and all of us will be okay
I'm not convinced that that's going to
happen that that's a it's it's pretty
optimistic I think it would be a little
bit absurd for me to fig thoughts like
that after having lived in the park and
been in such a contentious and
oppressive environment and really had it
drilled into me and the community around
me that right now in this city and
especially since having our encampment
removed the bee forces in new york city
that can choose when you're allowed to
speak and more often when you're not
allowed to speak right now do you have
more influence they legally have more
power and have more sway public opinion
is a different matter but it really can
only take you so far so I I'm not so
optimistic is to say that occupy wall
street has captured the imagination of
the American people
completely and from here on out all we
have to keep doing is organizing and
it's and it's going to work I don't
think we're to that point yet but I do
think that there were enough of those
heartbreaking stories shared in the park
and there are enough personal
connections forged enough people who got
hooked on protesting this very
exhilarating emotional experience that
those people are going to be looking for
more of those experiences and whether or
not Occupy Wall Street continues to
provide that people are going to keep
seeking that as an experience there were
by some counts 35,000 people marching on
our last big day of action on november
seventeenth there's a really really
great video of somebody as they're
marching across the Brooklyn Bridge and
they all Mic Check to everybody around
them and everybody might check back to
them and they yell this is my first
protest everybody else this is my first
protest back to them and then they say
this is the most amazing moment of my
life and that's a great moment to watch
anyway in somebody's life but what's
meaningful to me about that is that that
guy wherever he is right now might be
thinking I wish we could have another
one I want to go to another one when are
we doing it again and whether or not
occupy wall street stays strong and
keeps going or we have these you know
continuing staccato moments of you know
coming up and coming down and and
continuing this as a movement or not the
people who got hooked or people who got
deeply and emotionally affected by being
a part of this and there are tens of
thousands of them are going to continue
to seek those experiences and that has
to turn into something and it will turn
into something and I think that that
doesn't have to be just occupy wall
street protesters everybody is affected
in a democracy that is no longer a
democracy and an economy that no longer
serves the people that participate in
that account
and so for my just final note because
we're also affected by this because all
of us live in this country and
ninety-nine percent of us have some
involvement or something to benefit from
the most basic aims of Occupy Wall
Street succeeding whether or not anyone
considers themselves a part of Occupy
Wall Street or not and you don't need to
doesn't really matter to me people when
i think about folks at the business
school at columbia university or there
was a law school event last night people
were talking about afterwards do i need
to feel guilty about going into
corporate law and all of all of these
questions that people are asking if
you're not part of an activist community
and thank goodness that we're starting
these conversations right I think what's
important is that that from now on
hopefully it can't be ignored that there
can be a sort of Occupy Wall Street
sensibility that can be applied where
crowd you know laws that limit crowd
sourcing for small business funding can
be broken down there are efforts to do
that right now so that small businesses
can start from donations and friends
family members and communities instead
of banks that are will destroy you if
you can't pay your loan back you know so
there are and there are efforts like
that where you can apply an Occupy Wall
Street sensibility to law into business
and to all kinds of areas of life and
you know these initiatives to occupy
your your job and occupy your home and
what does that mean to just change the
way that you think and change the way
that you work around in the world and if
initiatives like that start to take hold
I think it will also be transformative
for all of us and hopefully have some
kind of a benefit where even if we don't
reclaim the commons and the democracy
and the
economy we can at least start to address
structures of systemic victimization and
of silencing people that we've accepted
for certainly but the few decades that
my life has been and the decades that
preceded it for way too long now thank
you Alicia my newfound friend so um my
name is Sonia Yesenia barragan I'm a PhD
student here in history I study Latin
American history and i'm a member of the
public relations working group of Occupy
Wall Street so I'm an organizer I've
been an activist for a very long time
mostly with immigrant rights labor
rights environmental justice and student
rights as an undergraduate I actually
have some stuff after you know sorry but
also I'm very short so you're not going
to miss anything oh sure
alrighty that works um and also I see
some comrades here from the movement who
have some occupied Wall Street Journal
newspapers in the back so please pick up
your copy when you leave so I'm also
going to talk taught to talk a little
bit about kind of the politics of
disruption that Suresh mentioned but
you'll hear that later on and I also i
agree with Jeffrey Sachs who was here
earlier when he was talking about this
development of a new civic engagement
but I guess first I would clarify that
the issue isn't just inequality in these
four elements that he brought up because
a lot of the free market advocates like
to constrain our point to inequality and
then use that as a way to argue that
inequality isn't necessarily that as
long as we're improving the conditions
of the people at the bottom the point
for many of us is rather bigger than
inequality the point is that the
economic system as it is currently
constituted isn't providing for the
people at the bottom in this country and
certainly no certainly less so in most
other countries and part of why this is
such a big deal specially United States
is because many middle-class people are
starting to feel their position slipping
as well so for a long time the political
dialogue in this country has been about
immediate relatively small-scale policy
issues and of course while those are
important they're critical such an
extreme emphasis on these issues have
served to obscure larger questions about
the general allocation of resources in
this country and around the world and
fundamentally questions of justice part
of what occupy wall street is trying to
say is that
shouldn't only focus on immediate issues
but also orient ourselves around
long-term struggles of economic justice
and if this is going to happen and I
mean this very seriously you know 5 10
15 20 years down the line we need to
start by asking the big questions such
as why does one in five children in this
country live in poverty why aren't
health care and education considered the
human rights that they are the fact that
occupy wall street has accomplished the
task of bringing issues of economic
justice into the national conversation
is an essential although often
overlooked precursor to any systemic
change so raising the issue is clearly
the first step this is what this
conference is about and the second step
or the next step is empowering
individuals and communities to determine
how these issues are affecting them most
severely and what solutions they'd like
to see to improve their state of affairs
direct action so for example I got
involved in part because two years ago
my family our family almost lost her
home due to a foreclosure in northern
New Jersey I come from a working-class
Latino Family and it was probably one of
the most terrifying experiences of my
life and so among the myriad of
accomplishments of Occupy Wall Street is
to one of them was to bring together
community organizations and families
who've lost their homes due to
foreclosures and so in response to these
massive foreclosures on on december six
but this in your calendar we are
launching a national day of action
resisting wrongful foreclosures we're
asking the 99 percent to pledge that
until banks do their part to help
homeowners we will non-violently resist
any attempts by them to take our homes
specifically we're going to have a march
to an undone
disclosed location of a home we're going
to occupy the home and with a block
party and a housewarming to follow and
so this isn't necessarily unique or
original in fact a lot of occupations
have a long long beautiful history in
this country but specifically the
occupation of foreclosed homes has been
done by our sister and brother occupy
movements throughout the United States
specifically in cleveland and boston and
providence and an oregon so in many ways
we're learning and sharing with each
other so here is a concrete example of
how we can shift from addressing larger
questions of injustice to empowering
communities to directly affect change
real change in their lives so I also got
involved with Occupy Wall Street on
because in addition to facing
foreclosures too many of my loved ones
including myself in my communities are
saddled with overwhelming student debt
in fact i think i read an article this
morning talking about him because by
david harvey as a geographer talking
about this new student debt issue being
form of modern debt peonage in our time
which is an interesting way to think
about it I think a few weeks ago for
example Occupy Wall Street help launch a
student debt refusal campaign and is
working on gathering 1 million
signatures from students who are willing
to boycott payments on their student
debt education and housing are basic
human rights that's what many of us
believe on occupy wall street I think
that's so many what most Americans
believe in this country and as we move
forward we will transition from raising
awareness to organizing resistance thank
you
in Madrid the indignados have been going
to neighborhoods and stopping
foreclosures from actually happening
have you are you doing that as well oh I
thought it was just taking over a house
that had already been abandoned sorry I
thought I thought you're going to take
over a house that had been abandoned no
this house is specifically under threat
of foreclosure yeah yeah they've been
doing that a lot in Madrid good so we're
out of time but we'll still take a
couple questions from the audience yes
sure first of all thank you for being
here for amazing discussion and rose and
Layla thank you i applaud all of you for
working on this um my question has to do
with media actually yes we're talking
about technology youtube and facebook
but what I find most annoying about this
movement was that there was not really
media coverage you turn on CNN or any
news channels and you hear about snooki
sections in Italy or Bieber's hair cut
but there was really not much coverage
and when I was back home in Kansas City
for thanksgiving people really have no
idea about wall street in the center of
america because there's really because
of no media coverage so i just want to
know what's your opinion about that and
how there's also fits i guess freedom of
speech and also the corruption of the
system itself thank
I'm not going to stand you can just
imagine me if you're in the back for me
and I can only speak for myself the and
the media blackout was not complete it's
you know it's an exaggeration but it
does kind of described that first week
in a way for me it was it's a little bit
empowering that the mainstream media
first decided not to talk about us and
then just been talked about us in
completely ridiculous terms because I
felt like we were irritated enough or
spurned enough to get really excited
about covering ourselves and that with
if the media coverage had been more
sympathetic or well-rounded and I can't
imagine a climate in the united states
where it would have been but if it had
been then the the the act of creating
our own media wouldn't have had the same
significance symbolically also i think
that it's been a really useful tool for
people who are younger and just getting
into this movement to be able to look at
media coverage as a way for them to
understand the way that public opinion
works in the united states and the way
that money works in the united states
and something that they're interested in
at that moment so to be able to use it
as this sort of self-reflexive
educational tool almost to say Lee look
you're here in this park right now
you've been talking to people for an
hour this is the experience you have go
home and watch CNN tonight you don't
even have to go as far as Fox News and
tell me if you feel like it's
representative or it's fair and then we
can talk about it tomorrow in person and
that those kinds of experiences were
possible like for those reasons and so
I'm pretty okay with the way that that
the mainstream media address Occupy Wall
Street I got plenty of the news I needed
by directly participate
and by watching democracy now so you
know so I felt right I got I got enough
news and i also got to watch a pretty
interesting circus at the same time now
i just want to add really quickly that i
mean i'm part of the press relations
group so we were specifically created to
address this initial blackout in the
beginning but I guess I also just want
to reiterate that I've been pleasantly
surprised by the amount of attention
that we've received and I think in some
seriousness as well I think that it
developed over time but I also just want
to add that we have our own media group
as well so they're folks who have
cameras you know who are making our own
documentaries making our own
advertisements newspapers sorry so
that's part of our apparatus to as a
social movement not not perhaps
notwithstanding the success of the
self-produced media I think we should
notice that it's a actually a power play
by the media that reaches they we talk
about the 99 percentile did this and
that there was a real censorship I mean
the night that it was cleared the cote
park was clear media was kept away
helicopters were kept away there is a
real censorship and I don't think that
with all due respect that a the social
media and all of the alternatives are
good and great and they're good as a
movement building etc but the real power
is with me with their networks and when
the when the country doesn't hear about
it it sees a power play by day they like
the very organizations that need to be
criticized I think it was almost good
that the first New York Times piece was
so offensive and patronizing because
there was such an outcry that they had
to reverse themselves actually if
they've done a sort of eat what they
usually do to protest right which is a
sort of even-handed thing buried in the
metropolitan news section then they
might have been able to maintain that
stance for longer I'm rushing through
because i know there's okay we're going
to do you and you and then we're done
hello I had two questions um the first
question has to do with law I have to
say I really enjoyed the discussion
today and it was great to get the
varying viewpoints but I was also
slightly surprised that there was no
national guild lawyer here and I wanted
to national guild lawyers are the
lawyers that have been actively involved
in representing occupy wall street
protesters who are arrested and I
thought that was that is a significant
very significant part of the wall street
occupy wall street movement and also
very significant part of protecting what
little rights they have so I you know I
just wanted to maybe hear more of your
perspective on that as people who were
actually there my second point or
question has more to do with i recently
read an article questioning the use of
the word occupy and i wanted to sort of
get your visa on that because it does
have colonial intonations and you know
you know you mentioned get your Latino a
person of color and some people of color
have expressed that they feel excluded
from occupy wall street and that it
still has this very pitcher echo or
colonialists sentiment that they feel
they can't really be comfortable
identifying with so if you can speak in
those two things for times sake the
second person who had a question she do
you want to come up and ask your
question and then we'll and then we'll
just hear from the panelists to wrap up
yep yeah well first of all thank you
again for for this panel it's for an
excellent to listen to your opinions
with regards to organizing I know that
some of you guys spoke about that I
wanted to ask basically what do you see
as being the ways in which people can
organize now I mean when we look back
you know we brought up the graph of the
civil rights movement for example what
an important fact of that was a black
churches they provided not only sort of
theoretical organizations but also
physical places to congregate and going
back earlier than that you know their
political parties that were much
stronger in terms of patronage and so
forth at the start of the century so I
guess I was wondering you know what what
is there for us now or can we sort of
rally behind great thank you very much
excuse my intrusion I'm really sorry
okay you have 30 seconds cuz you're well
over time I just want to go in another
direction on here for a second do you
think it's time to maybe blame bmv
American public because I think if
people you know let let go of watching
saving Super Bowl playing video games
then they might start paying attention
to this kind of thing okay so you need a
second movement in tandem that basically
open people eyes about that okay thank
you very much I'm really sorry cuz there
are other people who also want to ask
questions so if we can just quickly here
from the panelists and then we'll wrap
up thank you so much I'll just start
probably because for for two reasons one
my wife is an LD lawyer and she was
helping to do like she was down there as
you know with the green hat and is you
know isn't it does this sort of stuff
regularly and so yeah I mean it's clear
that but it's important also that our
use of the law is purely strategic sand
that that the nlg lawyers I know that
and their movement lawyers and they
helped us get people out of jail they
help negotiate sentences and it's purely
like it's not out of some sort of oh we
really you know respect the legal system
it's mostly like we're like that's what
we have to do to keep people I get
people out of jail and keep people safe
from the police
and so it's it's really it's like your
medics and the other thing is about the
use of the term occupy which so so it's
that I think it's really interesting
that actually that the politics of the
movement are so like tied up with the
with sort of internationalist politics
and anti-imperialist politics that
that's a conversation that happens sort
of regularly but i honestly think like
again sort of like having taken this
show on the road a little bit to
columbia and egypt and and in places
that nobody outside of the US is really
like oh my god they're calling it occupy
maybe that means that they either were
in favor of us occupying other places
nobody really thinks that and so so I
think it's outside of the US that that
no one's really sort of like worried
that that that Oh somehow occupy means
like in favor of like us occupation and
that's the last thing on the
organization I mean there's York first
role of Actos you organize where you are
and you you organize in the sights and
the spots that your are so graduate
student unionization is one and that's
you know that's a fight that's happening
that NYU is going through right now it's
a fight that has happened at Yale and
it's a fight that will put you in the
faces of your faculty and we'll we'll
get you um and and and it's and it's a
fire that because then you had political
organization and then you can do lots of
other stuff without political
organization so I think that's the role
you organize where you are
um two things one on the use of the word
occupy I remember thinking the very
beginning especially somebody who has
done work in activism in other countries
um I remember talking to a friend of
mine who is the child of refugees that I
remember her saying how how could they
choose that word I really wanted to go
and now I won't and me kind of rolling
my eyes and saying oh god I'm gonna go
anyway but why couldn't they have just
chosen another one this is this is going
to be so inconvenient for me morally and
and so 1 one thing with that it has been
a really really consistent conversation
I do have a lot of friends who are from
outside of the United States who have
consistently challenged me on the use of
that word I'm uncomfortable with the
term what makes me feel better as this
it was chosen not as this is an
occupation because we're seizing
something that that we don't have a
moral right to the my understanding of
the origin of that terminology is in old
like activism in occupying a factory or
occupying a like a space as part of
social activism as part as a part of an
activist action of some kind against a
business or corporation or something
like that where you occupy something
they belong and end this terminology was
developed kind of before a lot of the
politics of my generation came into play
and so like I remember somebody was
distributing pamphlets that had that
were printed or they were originally
written in the 60s about you know
nonviolent resistance techniques and and
it was using occupation terminology and
it and it that's when it clicked for me
like oh this was you know this this
vocabulary is old and an hour and our
critique of it is or it maybe was even
the late 50s or it likes it was just
something there was there's some moment
for me when I said this is really really
fix vocabulary that were you saying and
as long as we're talking about it I'm
going to decide to be okay with the with
the use of the word and for organizing
now I think it's really important for
people on universities to keep
organizing the majority of people in the
United States however don't go to a
university so I don't think that it's
going to being the focus of this
movement and people are going to keep
needing to organize where they are and
where they live it is space that's
relevant to them whether it's their
faith community or wherever I think that
needs to kind of come up organically and
then finally on the role of kind of
consumerism and the moral bankruptcy of
Americans and how that kind of erodes
our ability to participate in a
democracy and advocate for ourselves
effectively I think that that's not true
I don't I think that that relating I
found personally that relating to people
in a way that blames them or that that
confronts the suffering or the the
disempowerment or the feeling of
alienation and isolation that people
experience and then tend to express by
buying things by confronting that by
telling people that they're silly and
that the way that they use their time
and the money in their wallet is
incorrect and that there are more moral
ways for them to behave doesn't make
them want to look at me or listen to me
or appreciate how I'm human and that
there are conversations that I can have
with people and have about myself that
do engage humanity that do make us want
to change things that do get Americans
off of the couch and that transform the
way that we relate to each other and so
I think that that there are useful ways
to have conversations
those conversations start once that
engage in a positive way about common
humanity that we automatically turn off
the televisions very quickly in this
country very quickly I just want to add
really quickly about occupying the use
of that term there's a long history all
over the world of social movements
reappropriation otherwise oppressive
terms right I guess one of the most kind
of recent examples of that the United
States was development of this movement
or event called walk right which
was organized specifically to address
rape culture and gendered violence among
young women here in the United States
and of course there's valid valid
criticisms are for using that term I'm
not going to go into that but there is a
long history of reappropriation what it
means what those terms mean and using
them to empower people want the last
word sorry okay I just think that in
terms of organizing there is one thing
with the global demonstrations which
really we have to pay attention to if
this is not being transferred not
necessarily through the movement itself
or in some other ways but if this is not
transferred into political concrete
power it will be a lot of frustrations
and a lot of energy that wonderful
energy that is being wasted so it may be
that the movement doesn't have in
particular political agenda as such but
they in may be that it's not transferred
into a particular political party but we
have to remember that nature abhors
vacuum and politics is not any different
so the more disengaged the more
alienated people become from the process
it done the less has to be transferred
and transformed into political advocacy
and activism that leads to election
because if it doesn't lead to the
elections of the right people or the
good people we're going to end up with
people on the right I think we're
already seeing right this complete
anti-incumbent movement is actually
making things worse the Socialists
losing in Spain last week is not going
to help the situation the fall of pop
andreas government in Greece many of the
protesters I've talked to in Athens
that's what they wanted and the
experiences a moment of power but it's
not actually going to help them or make
things any better yeah that's right so
there's a lot of reasons to be
pessimistic so I'm glad so when tomorrow
headless aren't okay its one quickly at
first place the mana took over from
scouting Papademos who was a who taught
me here at economics that at a sepa so
it's nice to see a super person in
charge of fraud recover well max the
other thing is the other thing is gone I
think this is great i think is actually
a great thing I just hope you copyright
at the title itself so yeah yeah and I'm
sorry that we didn't get to hear from
moving good thank you for that so thank
you to the very patient audience are
fascinatingly stimulating panelists and
our wonderful organizer